all right here now with more former
senior adviser to president Trump Steven
Miller Fox News contributor Charlie hurt
all right let's start with Iowa latest
polls out of New Hampshire the thing I
worry about Steve Miller in New
Hampshire is they have this Open primary
uh provision that people can switch
affiliations they can Democrats can vote
say they're independent switch their
affiliation vote in the Republican
primary and at least 4,000 up to now
have done that okay uh Trump is leading
uh in most polls by double digits does
that have a big impact on this race on
Tuesday well it really is quite amazing
Sean that there's still the ability of
Democrats to determine the outcome of a
presidential primary in New Hampshire
but Republican voters deeply resent the
other party trying to determine their
nominee trying to switch over and vote
for Nikki Haley over for Donald Trump I
believe there will be a massive backlash
effect to this effort to court Democrat
voters to interfere in the primary and
ultimately that backlash effect will
drive president Trump's numbers even
higher particularly because after that
massive historic win in Iowa twice
anything that's ever happened in America
before he has unified the party behind
him you heard that incredible
presentation from Senator Rubio about
why he's endorsing president Trump and I
expect that his numbers in New Hampshire
in the weeks ahead are just going to
keep going or the days ahead I should
say are going to keep going up and
up yeah and I want to get your your uh
uh take on this trolley because they
want to extend out the Republican
primary as long as possible in the hopes
that Republicans you know spend all this
money going after each other um I just
don't like the system I mean even
governor sonunu who supporting Nikki
Haley fine for him even he acknowledged
to Neil Cavuto in an interview that you
know he doesn't like this either and
that the idea that some of these people
would try to muddy the waters and play
games like this in his State uh and then
have every intention of voting for the
Democrat they have no business being in
the Republican
primary well certainly every Republican
who's trying to keep this going needs to
be aware that the longer it keeps going
you know the longer uh we have this
internal fight as opposed to uh Donald
Trump turning his focus on on fighting
Joe Biden and getting Joe Biden out of
the White House um but I think it's
really interesting here you know uh we
saw the the effort by democrats and this
is an old along uh you know a tactic
that that both parties have tried over
the years where you have uh Democrat you
know Savvy Democrat voters in Iowa uh
participate in the Republican caucuses
trying to uh sew chaos in the other
party but this is what's sort of
interesting and I think a lot of people
people have sort of glossed over is
usually or always when that happens the
de Democrats are trying to get the
weakest candidate elected which I think
is really interesting here and we're
going to see it again in New Hampshire
where Democrats play in the Republican
primary or the Republican caucus in an
effort to get the weakest candidate uh
in all to get the nomination and in this
case that's Nikki Haley and I think it's
really interesting that that Democrats
seem to have a better Gras
of the real truth here which is Donald
Trump is the most formidable candidate
who could Face Donald Trump uh Joe Biden
in November he can prosecute the case
against Joe Biden better than anybody
and Democrats are terrified of facing
Donald Trump not only for because it's
going to be four more years of Donald
Trump but also because they realize he
is the most formidable candidate and so
that's why they're getting in trying to
cross over and supporting Nikki Haley in
the primary
yeah that that's why they they're saying
oh democracy and Peril that's one of
their big fear tactics but yet they're
the party that's trying to keep Donald
Trump off ballots in States uh how
ironic and they're the ones that want to
pile on more criminal charges as many as
possible uh and and weaponize our
justice system I mean it's a joke I'll
give you the last word uh quickly both
of you starting with
Steve this election is absolutely a
referendum on the survival of American
Dem democracy but the Grim Reaper for
American democracy and by the way he's
looking more and more like the Grim
Reaper visually is Joe Biden the
Democratic party is using the legal
system to try to imprison president
Trump to try to bankrupt president Trump
to try to take away the voices of the
American people to censor to Blacklist
to banish to jail it is fascism it is
authoritarianism if you want to save
American democracy in 2024 then you're
only hope and prayer is to vote for
Donald Trump you know they can't run on
one thing Charlie are you better off
than you were four years ago yeah
Charlie yeah exactly and Stephen is
exactly right about this if Democrats
get away with these tactics and and win
an election doing this they will never
use any other tactics to win an
election they can't run on a positive
record cuz they don't have one it really
is that simple so it's going to be
negative negative the entire time scare
people the usual tactics and um that's
all they're going to want to talk about
and Joe will probably hide in the
basement I don't know which basement
Delaware the White House he'll be in
some basement all right thank you both
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else